[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
thank you
present
almost forever she's in it
there's a serial killer
I want to respect it
first anniversary and
what makes you think I know so cheap
I thought you'd be curious
I think I fell off of this stuff
don't you
you have victories
oh
yeah
[Applause]
it's violence
and so baroque
oh
it makes little puzzles doesn't he
show meticulous
thank you've been plenty of this his
whole life
I know who he is
[Music]
a nobody wants to be somebody
it's a mayor
the commissioner
yeah
he's got ambition you think his motor is
political oh no this is very very
personal
he feels these people have all wronged
him
he finally goes way back
on healed all and stolen much money
why is she writing to me maybe
he's a fan of yours
or maybe he's got a grudge against you
too
maybe Lauren's main course
any fairies
oh yeah really you're normally so ahead
of the garbage
something is different
this is very upsetting to you let's get
back to him why you are so much more fun
I'm not here to talk about me what are
you here to talk about I want to know
how he thinks you know exactly how he
thinks you read this file
mask Adventure
so he's even more right Jason
oh are you afraid he makes you look soft
I'm wasting my time
okay okay
tell you what I really think
I think
you don't really care about his motives
I think somewhere deep down
you're just terrified
because you're not sure what he's wrong
huh
you think they deserved it
you think they deserved it
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]